nineteen hundred and things in Europe
are getting a bit tense why one reason
was that a series that defensive
alliances had been drawn up meaning that
the next European war was going to be a
doozy to make matters worse there were
several areas of contention that could
lead to the outbreak of said war the
first was the ongoing anglo-german naval
arms race as the recently formed german
empire ruled by kaiser wilhelm ii sought
to build a fleet large enough to
challenge the royal navy the second was
french resentment over its loss of
alsace-lorraine to germany back in 1871
the third was the rivalry between the
austro-hungarian Empire in the Russian
Empire for dominance in the Balkans and
the fourth was the rivalry between
Britain and Russia for control over the
Middle East knowing that a major war was
potentially on the horizon you think
that the great powers of Europe these
nations would act calmly to prevent that
but you'd be wrong over the following
decade in a bit there were several
potential sparks for the outbreak of
this war France and Britain had signed
some agreements collectively known as
the on tante cordial which made them
allies in foreign policy but importantly
it wasn't a mutual defense pact
soon after this in 1905 came the first
moroccan crisis in which Vilhelm ii gave
his support to moroccan independence
which upset the french because they saw
it as a part of their sphere of
influence it was agreed that Morocco
would stay under French influence but
with a foreign run police force 1907 saw
Britain and Russia patched things up
where they divided the Middle East up
between them thus it seemed that things
were calming down but then
austria-hungary annex Bosnia in 1908
without consulting anyone which led to
Russia getting very annoyed more
tensions erupted from the collapse of
the Ottoman empires European territories
this led to the birth of the Balkan
states who by 1913 looked like this by
1914 things were very tense but
fortunately nothing interesting was
happening except for a visit of the heir
to the austro-hungarian throne Franz
Ferdinand to Bosnia to inspect troops
there whilst in Bosnia he managed to get
a tiny bit assassinated by Bosnian Serb
coal Gavrilo Princip the Emperor of
austria-hungary Franz Joseph was
unsurprisingly furious and the
assassination gave him pretext for war
with whom Serbia this was because it was
assumed that Serbia whom principal
wanted Bosnia to be united with had
something to do with it the turmoil that
followed this is known as the July
crisis during this Germany issued the
blank cheque whereby it gave its full
support to Austria in any course of
action it chose to take Austria Hungary
wanted to subdue Serbia either by
diplomacy or by force and this would
almost inevitably mean war with Russia
who saw itself as the protector of all
Slavs for Germany support
austria-hungary made sense since it had
determined that if it left Russia to its
own devices Russia would become far too
powerful to defeat in a war by about
1917 as such an ultimatum with the list
of demands was issued to Serbia Serbia
refused and on the 28th of July
austria-hungary declared war on them and
Russia began to mobilize its military
Germany demanded they stop they didn't
and on the 1st of August Germany
declared war on Russia France then
started to mobilize and on the 3rd
Germany declared war on them too
the German plan for the war was simple
hold off the Russians in the East whilst
the large force cut through Luxembourg
and Belgium in what was called the
Schlieffen Plan the idea was that the
Germans would capture Paris and force a
French surrender after which they could
turn their full might on the Russians
who would take a long time to mobilize
on the 4th Germany entered Belgium after
it refused to grant the passage of
German troops Britain had guaranteed
Belgium's independent since 1830 but the
Germans weren't expecting the British to
actually be willing to go to war for it
they were wrong by mid-august the
respective site of the war look like
this you'll note that Italy hadn't come
to the aid of the rest of the Triple
Alliance and the reason for this was
that this was only a defensive pact and
so Italy wasn't obligated to do anything
and so they didn't so the balance of
power
early on favoured Germany in
austria-hungary together known as the
Central Powers Germany had a large
population it was heavily industrialized
and at the beginning had more been
available to fight austria-hungary was
also there whereas Russia on paper had a
terrifyingly large army but it was
spread out poorly trained and under
equipped France also had a well-equipped
conscript army but it was much smaller
and Britain didn't have any conscripts
at all but instead had a fairly small
but robust professional army the German
army started by quickly pushing through
Belgium and in the zones they occupied
they brutally repressed any Belgium
resistance Germany advanced to here but
it was halted at the First Battle of the
Marne by the British in the French this
ended any hopes of a quick war and the
Germans retreated where they dug in and
began what the conflict is most famous
for trench warfare after man came the
race to the scene which both sides
advanced north trying to outflank each
other and after this the Western Front
came to a standstill
so trench warfare heavily favored the
defenders since in order to attack the
enemy soldiers had to go over the top
and leave the safety of the trenches
they were then exposed to enemy machine
guns barbed wire and all the other
horrors of war both sites would spend a
lot of time and money developing weapons
and tactics to break this stalemate on
the Eastern Front the Russian Empire did
well at first and pushed into Germany
this advance came to a grinding halt at
the Battle of Tannenberg in which food
marshal Paul von Hindenburg
crushed the Russian army to the south
austria-hungary concentrated on
attacking Serbia which did not go well
and Russia advanced into the empire soon
after this the Central Powers received a
boost when the Ottoman Empire entered
the war on their side
Montenegro would also join the on tonton
by the end of the year the front lines
looked like this after this the methods
are fighting a modern war started to
evolve rapidly England was subject to
Zeppelin raids and Germany debuted the
use of chlorine gas mid 1915 saw the
Gallipoli campaign which spoiler alert
ended in disaster this was where the
ontong tried to strike at the heart of
the Ottoman Empire but again defensive
warfare was easy when a lots of people
died for nothing
1915 also witnessed the sinking of the
Lusitania a passenger ship which was
carrying people and weapons to Britain
from the United States the sinking was
part of the German naval doctrine of
unrestricted submarine warfare in which
German u-boats would attack shipping
indiscriminately in the hopes of
starving Britain out of the war
soon after this Italy joined the war on
the side of the un-- tante the Italians
failed to advance quickly into
austria-hungary and so trench warfare
the war wasn't just limited to Europe
though troops of the British and Russian
empires were advancing into bottom and
lands and both sides clashed in Africa
as well Japan also joined the war and
nabbed all of the German colonies in the
Pacific in Australia captured Guinea
late 1915 so Serbia finally full but not
until Bulgaria joined the Central Powers
and invaded from the south the Russians
who had been struggling for a while
we're now in mass retreat and so sonic
lists ii decided that he would take
personal charge to fix things 1916 saw
montenegro conquered the Fayed Easter
rising in Ireland and attempts by both
sides to break the deadlock on the
Western Front the Germans launched the
Battle of Verdun
during which lots of people died for a
whole load of nothing and later the
British launched the Battle of the Somme
which was more of the same
soon after this Romania entered the war
and was swiftly conquered this was also
the year that so the main British and
German fleets clash at the gargantuan
Battle of Jutland in which Germany
attempted to break British naval
dominance they did not
soon after this came the Brusilov
offensive on the Eastern Front which
would the Russians push back to here
also Franz Josef proved that he could
actually die and was succeeded by
Charles the first 1916 was important
from a technological standpoint because
it saw the introduction of the tank by
the British and they were largely
effective when they weren't breaking
down that was so by 1917 everyone was
getting a bit tired of this war stuff
but not much could be done since both
sides wanted to remake the balance of
power in Europe which the other side
could never accept the Central Powers
wanted Europe to look like this and the
on Tom wanted this the
contempt with the war was particularly
strong in Russia and February so rioting
which soon became the February
Revolution they saw Nicholas the second
abdicate and Russia become a republic
the new provisional government there
would importantly not end the war
discontent wasn't limited to Russia
though austria-hungary was basically
coming apart at the seams and in Germany
political pressures were dividing the
country this was exacerbated by the
British naval blockade which prevented
Germany from importing the food it
desperately needed which induced hunger
and starvation in certain parts of the
country Woodrow Wilson the recently
reelected president of the United States
was keen to stay out of the war but had
sympathies to the on tante after some
more unrestricted submarine warfare and
finding out about the Zimmermann
telegram in which Germany invited Mexico
to invade the US America joined the war
against the Central Powers Greece after
a lot of pressure joined the war on the
side of the un-- tante
the late year also saw the october
revolution in which the Communists
seized control of russia russia then
withdrew from the war and after long
negotiations with the central powers
russia ceded this territory in 1918
germany then launched the spring
offensive against the ontong to win the
war before too many Americans arrived a
lot of people died some land was taken
nothing changed and the war dragged on
austria-hungary continued to break down
and most of the fronts were still a
stalemate in southern Europe Greek
Serbian British and French troops
advanced into Bulgaria which had its own
disgruntled population and so it signed
an armistice the British were now
advancing into the Ottoman Empire with
the help of its rebelling Arabian
population and the neighboring peoples
under the guidance of TE Lawrence better
known as Lawrence of Arabia
the British had secured their help by
promising them this land
the British had lied by late October the
on tante had captured the important city
of Damascus and the Ottoman signed an
armistice in October the 30th four days
later after the Italians had finally
pushed into austro-hungarian territory
Charles the first signed an armistice in
about six seconds later the Empire fell
apart realizing the war was lost bill
ham the second applicated on November
the 11th Germany signed an armistice the
war was over in 1919 the peace was
formalized in the Treaty of Versailles
which limited the size of Germany's
armed forces demanded hefty reparations
and reduced its territory to this the
Treaty of Trianon divided the hungarian
half of the austro-hungarian Empire and
gave territory to Romania in the new
kingdom of Serbs Croats and Slovenes
later known as Yugoslavia the Treaty of
San Germain onlay divided the Austrian
half creating Czechoslovakia giving
territory to Poland and also Italy but
not as much as they had been promised
Bulgaria was
tripped of this territory the Ottoman
Empire was supposed to lose this the
Turks refused to accept this a war broke
out the Turks won and this became the
Republic of Turkey with the rest of the
Empire's territories going to Britain
and France the war had seen about 8
million military debt with Russia
Germany and France seeing the lion's
share the war had been started over
Imperial pride millions of men had died
in the vain hope of bringing their
generals and emperors glory in a quick
resolution to the war tactical and
flexibility combined with revolutionary
methods of warming the scores of men who
didn't have to die did so with such a
heavy price paid what did the war
achieve honestly not much it had brought
about the death of four major empires
and the rise of new nations from their
ashes ultimately what were one's
greatest legacy was that he created the
conditions necessary for the outbreak of
world war two I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching the
special thanks to James Bissonnette
Thomas guest Strich Adam Harvey and
Winston Cawood coward I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly if you'd like
to know more about World War one there
are some book recommendations in the
description below